alors michel mercier vous avez fait
beaucoup de choses par amour on faisait
quand même resté une fois 22 jours sans
manger par amour c'est vrai et alors
interview par amour
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que parmi vous seriez prête à
vous déguiser en ailes de john bas à
l'appel plusieurs
amants sont comme ça
ne va pas est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à cacher quelqu'un qu'il
vient de tuer par amour possible est-ce
que paramo vous soyez prêtes à vous
mettre à la drogue germa pas un bon vous
l'aimez pas vraiment là avait
pas quand on aime il ya des choses qui
est ce que par un faux vous soyez prêtes
à prendre 17 kg serment pas j'essaye
d'aller perdre alors là c'est bien
jusqu'aux par amour vous seriez prête à
embrasser cent fois ses chaussettes
sales
pas présent par amour bon ok d'accord
seul hockey d'amour à ses chaussettes
son propre passé mieux salle ce type de
cours on nous a appris ici que c'était
des chaussettes sales elle à dakar ok ok
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
accepter quelques petites infidélités
jamais jamais non je les ai acceptées
c'était trop tard
donc par amour vous accepteriez pas
qu'il est une maîtresse après que
celui-là angélique et quand il en avait
je ne le savais pas comment un si
c'était terminé
auparavant vous soyez pas prêtes à vivre
à trois avec la mettra jamais d'accord
n'a sûrement pas est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à fréquenter des clubs
échangistes
si angélique au kid cudi
colombelles
est-ce que par amour ou seriez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuelle ça oui
c'est marrant je n'ai jamais
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vendre votre corps pour lui non
mais c'était touche l'argent pour une
fois
il pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux